needs to make the sound like yeah today
I'm going to attempt to recreate sound
from a few popular movie scenes now I've
always been fascinated with Foley
because when it's done right you have no
idea that it's been done at all i sat
down with Foley artist Matt Davies with
studio unknown to learn a little bit
more about his tips and secrets when it
comes to fully worth a lot of people
aren't aware of the fact that when you
make a film when you shoot the film when
you get the footage these sounds don't
come with the footage that you shoot or
it's very rare that they do quite often
the goal is so focused on the dialogue
that a lot of those extra sounds are
lost in the process our goal is to be
felt in the mix of a film but not
necessarily heard it's a blessing and a
curse because we're doing our jobs
properly then the audience maybe should
never know what's gone in even the most
mundane sounds that you hear in films
typically had to be added Foley is so
much of a marriage between those two
sides where it's very physical and
hands-on and you're creating with your
hands for the sole purpose of making a
sound and so the the thing that you're
creating whether it's assembling
different things together might not ever
be seen by anybody the answer isn't
always using authentic it's often simple
things that you need to do sounds for
that require a little bit of head
scratching to figure out we can't always
have the literal items so what weird
things do I need to slap together to
just make this simple sound we're going
to use just a few everyday objects
around the house and see what kind of
sounds we can create my sister we're
gonna try and do
these phony sounds together are you
ready yeah all right love to do this and
this we've seen burglaries bastard it's
just absolutely every wicked maybe toast
some bread yes yes yes yes yes you can
say that sad that we're not doing celery
for broken bones because that's what I
know about this just do that for fun
yeah yeah
carrots why not perfect okay it's going
really and we have to be super quiet
because the sound we're creating you're
gonna try and put it in dude laughing
yeah they cut it you'll be the person so
you'll be their waiters okay so you guys
get the sound be like whoever puts them
in the bowl you just make the sound look
yeah he's going real quick okay
I think we got it I think I think we I
think we got it and I need money Alden
last week it was movie castaway it's
just perfect because it's just really
all about putting in a blazer so he
picks it up so it's a very like okay
force and we can use the litter box
that's that was really that was really
hard really hard and really hard I don't
know how they get the timing down one
thing for me that's really fascinating
about it is just the performative aspect
of creating these sounds if you can
definitely have to create it your entire
body has to get into it it's a very fun
thing about Foley that it it's all
around us things like footsteps and very
commonplace sounds the joke is kind of
like Foley is always like coconuts for
horse hooves and celery for bones
breaking it also is so much more it's
it's amazing seeing people discover
Foley and just simply discover that it's
a thing you're you're kind of honoring
the physicality of anything that's on
screen it nobody may notice but they're
definitely gonna feel something
you
[Music]